la parole est maintenant notre collègue
bruno belin pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole monsieur
le président monsieur le président mes
chers collègues monsieur le premier
ministre
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé je ne vais pas vous
parler monsieur le ministre
davy russe inconnu encore de tous il ya
quelques mois
venu du bout du monde et pour lequel
nous n'aurions pas été prêt je vous
parle d'un virus dont la puissance
contagieuse est connue de tous
mondialement depuis 1918 et pour lequel
un vaccin existe depuis 1944
chacun sait la virulence contagieuse la
virulence saisonnière du virus de la
grippe
or nous ne sommes pas prêts nous ne
sommes pas prêts trois chiffres 7
millions de français ont d'ores et déjà
retiré en pharmacie un vaccin inquiet
par la situation sanitaire qui nous
entoure
15 millions de personnes bénéficieront
d'une prise en charge en fonction de
leur situation à risque
or 13 millions de doses vaccinales ont
été seulement préparer que comptez vous
faire monsieur le ministre pour protéger
les habitants de ce pays pour éviter la
rupture de stock en officine dès cette
semaine alors que nous entrons dans la
période optimale pour se faire vacciner
on vous répondre la parole et lorsque
13h l'état a grillé attaqué de la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur belin permettez moi tout
d'abord de vous féliciter pour votre
élection récente et je suis ravi d'avoir
l'honneur de répondre à votre première
question en tant que sénateur car j'ai
apprécié j'ai apprécié le travail que
nous avons pu mener ensemble l'année
dernière en tant que président du
conseil départemental de la vienne sur
la protection de la protection de
l'enfance
alors cette campagne de vaccination vous
l'avez évoqué a débuté le 13 octobre
dernier elle se poursuivra jusqu'au 31
janvier prochain et votre question et la
presse
a fait écho d'un certain nombre de
questions qui sont légitimes d'une part
tout le monde doit-il se faire vacciner
et aurons-nous suffisamment de vaccins
alors concernant la première la première
des interrogations rappeler à la haute
assemblée que la haute autorité de santé
a rendu dès le 20 mai dernier un avis
qui confirmait que cette vaccination
soit doit s'adresser en priorité aux
professionnels de santé aux personnes
les plus fragiles notamment les
personnes âgées et celles qui sont à
risque d'infection grave à la copie de
19 vaccination et professionnelle répond
à un double objectif que je me permets
de rappeler ici pour rappeler aussi aux
professionnels la nécessité de se
vacciner pour protéger tout d'abord les
protéger et leur permette de continuer à
assurer leurs activités de soins est
donc soulagé
l'ensemble du système de soins mais
également protéger les patients avec
lesquels ils sont en contact et
notamment dans les ep dans les hôpitaux
dans les établissements médico-sociaux
et dans les ehpad
concernant le nombre de doses
disponibles ensuite qui se réfère à la
question plus précisément que vous posez
me permette de rappeler que l'objectif
de cette campagne vaccinale n'est pas
que 100% des français soient vaccinés
mais 75% conformément aux
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et compte tenu de
l'anticipation d'une demande accrue
cette année nous avons fait le
nécessaire pour mettre à disposition 30
% de doses supplémentaires par rapport
aux 12 millions consommées lors de la
précédente campagne
ça se traduira par un approvisionnement
continu nous avons bien conscience
phénomène de tension qui peut exister
dans certaines officines mais c'est
jaune seront constituées par les vaccins
qui sont commandés par les officines par
les laboratoires pharmaceutiques ou
encore les établissements de santé mais
aussi pour la première fois par la
constitution d'un stock d'état je peux
donc vous assurez monsieur le sénateur
que l'état fait tout pour protéger nos
concitoyens contre cette épidémie de
grippe
monsieur là je craque nous ne devions le
pays de la pénurie pénurie de médecins
pénurie de moyens dans les hôpitaux
pénurie de masques pénurie djel pénurie
sur blues pénurie de tests pénurie de
lits de réanimation pénurie
d'anticipation ce qui est encore plus
grave pénurie de vaccins
la préparation est une faute monsieur le
ministre j'espère que nous allons nous
mobiliser les uns les autres pour qu' il
y ait moins de pénurie et d'incurie dans
ce pays
[Applaudissements]